if the world warms by four degrees
oceans rise overtaking heavily populated
Delta's home to a billion people
Bangladesh washed away
Egypt inundated Venice submerged
glaciers disappear shutting off the flow
of fresh water to billions more northern
Canada becomes one of the planet's most
bountiful agricultural zones while a
beach in Scandinavia could be the next
San Tropez the entire West Antarctic Ice
Sheet could collapse sending sea levels
rising even further this could be our
world plus four degrees I have four
degrees we really do begin to see a
planet which is completely
unrecognizable from the one we know
today
[Music]
we will see the possible drying up of
some of the most important rivers in the
world and this will endanger the
survival of tens and even hundreds of
millions of people if the planet is ever
four degrees warmer one of its great
rivers will be self-destructing at both
ends from a high mountain glacier to the
Indian Ocean locals call it mother
Ganges the holiest River in India
perhaps in all the world
millions of devout pilgrims gather each
year in a mass ritual to celebrate the
rivers birthday when it is said the
goddess Ganga came to earth to save her
people from drought Himalayan rivers are
the wellspring of life for over a
billion people in China Nepal and India
climate scientists predict India could
be one of the countries where the impact
of global warming takes its greatest
toll unless we begin to slow global
warming in fewer than four decades the
Ganges could be a river fighting for its
very life
[Music]